(upbeat music)
(humming)
(laughing)
- My life is being made right now so much.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Hi everyone, I am Emma
Bunton from the Spice Girls,
and I am here to freak out some fans.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- I was, and I am, and I will remain
a gigantic Spice Girls
fan my whole entire life.
It's mainly the reason I feel like
a confident woman in my life.
- I actually live my life
according to the philosophy of the Spice.
- I had a Spice Girls
themed birthday party,
where I only invited enough people
to fill out the Spice Girls.
- And they were just the first girls
I could identify with
as adolescence/tween.
- I had all the dolls,
I had all the little fan books.
I had a Spiceworld movie thing.
I had the Polaroid camera.
- I had their posters on my wall
and learned all their dance routines.
- The Spice Girls were legit my life.
- If I could say one thing to
the Spice Girls, it would be,
- Honestly, this is gonna sound so cheesy,
but it would be thank you.
- Thank you so much for existing.
- Thank you for making me a powerful
and empowered woman.
- You were a huge part of my childhood.
(uplifting instrumental music)
(man mumbling)
(Emma mumbling)
- No!
I'm sorry, I don't mean to yell at you.
- I want to say thank you.
- Can I get a zigazig ah?
Or something?
- What the hell?
Why are you so cool?
Oh my God!
- And I'm still so brightly--
- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
- What are you doing here?
- Oh my God you said my name.
(both laughing)
- And for (screaming).
- What do you mean?
- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
- Okay, I'm freaking out.
- Nice to see you.
- Hi!
- Hi.
- Can I hug you?
- Yes, let's hug it out.
Zigazig ah.
- Oh my God.
Pause.
No.
- Oh my God.
- I love your stories.
- Oh my God, I feel like
I'm really gonna cry.
- I just can't even believe
that I'm literally sitting here right now.
- The Spice Girls mean everything to me
and continue to mean everything to me,
and I really think that you guys formed
a whole entire generation of women
who believed in themselves
because you existed.
- Can I really just say thank you though?
I don't want to cry, but whatever.
- Oh my goodness.
- As a young gay kid,
it was a thing of like,
"Oh look I'm different," and I would read
about you guys and what
you guys went through,
and I was like, "You know what?
"I'm gonna be gay, and I'm gonna own it."
And it was like girl power,
and it was like gay power
and Latino power.
I'm like, I can't believe
I'm next to you right now.
Thank you so much.
- I feel like the Spice Girls
is why I was running
around at 10 years old
screaming girl power.
- What did that feel like,
to know that you influenced an era?
- It was an inedible time,
but it was amazing to watch
other women support us in the way that,
and girls as you did.
It was just so nice to
have that support and fans
and people that believed
in what we were doing.
And we just felt like we had a message,
we had great music, just
writing our own songs
was really important
to us, 'cause we wanted
for you guys to identify
with whatever we wrote.
We feel like we always
want to thank our fans
for being so supportive of us.
- Oh my God!
I have so many questions for you.
Do you ever buy big platforms anymore?
I have so many questions--
- Are these platforms?
- Yeah, those are pretty big.
They're not quite as big, okay.
- Not as (mumbles) but I broke my ankle
quite a few times on those things.
- Did you really?
- Yeah, I actually did.
- Did you guys really put boogers
underneath manager's desks and stuff?
- (laughing) Yeah.
- [Man] Is that real?
- We did some vile things.
- I love it.
- [Woman] Whats your
favorite Spice Girls song?
- 2 Become 1 is my favorite, I think.
But I love Say You'll Be There as well.
- That, yeah, that's the best.
Oh my God.
This is crazy.
- I'm so grateful for this experience.
You don't even know.
I'm still shaking.
- I spoke to Geri this morning.
And I said that I was doing this,
and she was like, "Oh my
goodness, so much fun!"
- We just go to the camera
and do a girl power?
- Girl power.
(laughing)
- What a damn Monday.
- And the biggest fight I
ever got into my dad with was
whether the Spice Girls or the Beatles
would go down in history as
the biggest group of all time.
So I'm very dedicated.
I'm gonna have a heart attack.
The video will go viral, because it'll be
A Spice Girl Killed Me.